Please
come to play with the number of keys. What's wrong with the famous car? It's a girls-only
gathering, but I
'm thinking that I'd like you to see it without listening to the new pajamas.
I think the air
pajamas are cute, but that's right.
I'm already having the maid return to the room. It
looks like it's far away, so
there are only two of us in this room.
No
[Music]
Ah,
Mei-san seems to have forgotten that I confessed the other day. Maybe it was a dream because the
smart key difference was so normal that I forgot my parents.
I dared to treat him as usual so as not to bother him
, but thank you, but
if the feelings I finally conveyed seem to be a dream,
I'll try not to use them anymore.
Without it,
Mei-san is too defenseless
[Music]
Kita
I entered to be careful-I
just come alone in 3 volumes at night I
can't complain no matter what I do
re
[Music]
I'll put up with this  But
if you're a maid, it'll be irreparable.
I realized that I'm a woman a little more.
[Music]
[Applause]
Ah ah ah ah ah
tan
uh